There is no single character that represents
One Piece as well as the man, the woman, the
myth, the legend: Bon Kurei.
No matter what we thought upon our first impressions
in Alabasta, there isn’t a One Piece fan
out there that didn’t fall in love with
Bentham / Mr. 2 Bon Kurei- a character with
seemingly as many names as faces.
At least, I can’t comprehend someone seeing
Bentham’s multiple heroic sacrifices and
not weeping over the true power of friendship
that he demonstrates.
You see, Bon Kurei *is* One Piece.
…
The series, not the treasure.
That would be the plot twist to end all plot
twists.
No, what we should say is that Bentham embodies
what One Piece is as a series.
So, today we’re going to talk about Un,
Deux, Trois ways that this character demonstrates
some of the story’s most important traits
and themes.
**First, Bentham is a wacky character who
delivers a huge emotional impact.**
If there are two barriers to entry for new
One Piece readers, they’re the series’
length and Oda’s art style.
However, while 1,000 chapters seems daunting
at first, once readers are caught up, they’ll
learn the truth: One Piece is *not* too long.
It’s actually too short.
But if you’re watching this channel, you
probably already know that.
What we should talk about instead is the other
complaint we might hear from people hesitant
to come along for the voyage - Oda’s art
style.
Compared to edgier, darker looking Shonen
like Bleach or Naruto, One Piece looks positively
cartoonish.
In fact, Eiichiro Oda’s character designs
look rather unique within the world of manga
as a whole - he has a style all his own that
looks more Bugs Bunny than Berserk.
People are often initially put off by this
art style, claiming it looks too silly or
unserious.
But what these readers don’t yet realize
is that that silliness is one of One Piece’s
greatest strengths.
One Piece *is* silly - it’s goofy and ridiculous
- it’s genuinely funny and will make you
laugh out loud again and again.
But one of the beautiful things about that
comic tone is that it makes the deeper emotional
beats hit that much harder.
The humor disarms us - we let our guard down.
Then, because we’re initially just along
for a silly pirate adventure, the audience
is reduced to tears when we learn that our
crew mates have the saddest backstories known
to man.
This blue-nosed reindeer?
He will make you cry.
This speedo-wearing cyborg?
*He* will make you cry.
This skeleton with an afro?
Yes, even he will make you cry.
Bentham functions as a perfect example of
this phenomenon.
When we first meet Bon-Chan, it’s as Mr.
2 Bon Kurei - an agent of Crocodile’s Baroque
Works organization.
By the way, while I was researching for this
video I learned something that…wow, I feel
like I should have known all along.
Even though we often refer to Bentham as Bon-Clay
as if that’s their name, it turns out that
Bon Kurei actually refers to a specific night
in the Japanese Obon Festival.
So, whereas most of the Baroque Works agents
feature male and female pairs with the man
being named after a number and the woman being
named after a holiday, I.e., Mr. 3 and Miss
Goldenweek or Mr. 4 and Miss Merry Christmas.
Bentham, however, being genderfluid has both
code names.
Surprisingly progressive for Sir Crocodile…or
not very surprising if we accept the Croco-Mom
theory.
And as a quick note before we get into the
rest of the video, we’re using he/him pronouns
for Bentham since those are what are used
in the manga and anime, but it is important
to note that the character has referred to
himself as a man and a woman.
But back to how Bentham exemplifies a wacky
character with hard hitting emotional impact.
When we first meet Mr. 2 Bon Kurei, the audience
is struck by possibly the most ridiculous
character design in the series up to that
point.
He’s a drowning ballerina adorned with massive
“2” shaped swans and a make-up job worse
than Buggy’s.
Especially in the anime, the over-the-top
drama in every one of his lines is masterfully
performed by voice actor Kazuki Yao - a performer
whose energy is so unmatched he would eventually
be welcomed into the crew proper as the voice
of Franky.
He’s relegated to such a position of comic
relief all throughout this scene and the remainder
of Alabasta, that we can hardly predict it
coming when in the end of the arc, he disguises
himself and his crew as the Straw Hats so
that the real Straw Hats can evade capture
by the Marines.
All along, Mr. 2 has been espousing the power
of true friendship in an exaggerated, melodramatic
manner, but suddenly when the crew’s livelihood
is on the line, it’s Bentham who puts his
money where his mouth is in a moment of complete
sacrifice.
Seeing such goofy characters deliver on powerful
emotional moments is one of the touchstones
of One Piece, and Bon Kurei is emblematic
of this feature.
**Secondly, Bon-Chan is representative of
one of One Piece’s central themes: Friendship.**
There’s a good reason that so many Western
fans know the word nakama - “companion”
or “friend.”
During Bentham’s first meeting with the
straw hats, they become fast friends.
Mr. 2 and his entertaining copy ability mesmerizes
the more “immature” crew mates - Luffy,
Usopp, and Chopper.
In fact, they slot in so well with each other
that they immediately become lifelong friends.
However, once the crew realized that Bentham
was in fact an agent of Baroque Works who
now possessed the ability to change into any
of their crew at will, the Straw Hats devised
a countermeasure against this technique.
They drew X’s on their wrists and then covered
them by tying a bandage around the X.
What at first was a clever way to defend against
Mr. 2’s devil fruit power set the groundwork
for one of the most emotional moments of the
Alabasta saga.
These X’s allowed for their silent goodbye
to Vivi.
While they couldn’t risk revealing their
close connection to the princess to the Marines,
raising these marks into the air allowed them
to demonstrate their bonds to one another,
signifying their undying friendship.
Before this, when the Marines are in heavy
pursuit of the Straw Hats, they’re able
to escape Black Cage Hina when Mr. 2 disguises
his ship and crew as the Straw Hats, acting
as decoys.
Even though sailing to meet Vivi at the rendezvous
point will put them directly in the path of
the Marines, Bon Kurei sacrifices himself
and his crew in order to give them the chance
to say farewell to their friend.
Bon Clay has a power that seems inherently
deceitful - he uses it to impersonate Nefertari
Cobra and kick off a war in Alabasta as part
of Crocodile’s plan.
Posing as someone else has its roots in subterfuge
and trickery.
We see this especially in its former user,
Higurashi, who used it to fool Oden into thinking
Momonosuke was in danger, allowing Kaidou
to make the finishing blow in their battle.
However, in Bentham’s sacrifice, we see
the nature of the fruit subverted.
He’s still using the Mane Mane no Mi to
trick someone - in this case Hina - but for
the greater good of allowing his friends to
continue their adventure.
Mr. 2 Bon Kurei is one of the first of Luffy’s
enemies who’s turned into a friend.
As Mihawk thought at Marineford, Luffy’s
most dangerous ability is turning those around
him into allies.
In Impel Down, the second arc to heavily feature
Bentham, this trait of Luffy’s is exemplified.
What began in Alabasta with Mr. 2 rallying
to Luffy’s aid became an entire rag-tag
crew of Luffy’s former enemies becoming
invaluable allies.
Even Bon Kurei’s former employer, Crocodile,
would join Luffy’s side in the Paramount
War.
And once again, Bentham would make an ultimate
sacrifice for the sake of friendship, allowing
everyone to escape the impenetrable prison
of Impel Down.
You know, speaking of Crocodile: he has an
81,000,000 bounty.
Since I have around 580,000 subscribers.
- if we converted that into dollars and then
converted *those* into berries, I would have
a 59,000,000 berry bounty.
Making me significantly less dangerous than
this slimy man right here.
So please help me change that by subscribing
to the channel and raising my bounty!
**The third and final way that Bon Kurei embodies
the themes of One PIece is by representing
the absolute freedom that Luffy seeks to bring
to the world.**
If there’s one theme that echoes through
the series even more powerfully than that
of friendship, it is the theme of freedom.
Luffy wants to become the Pirate King - the
person with the most freedom on the sea.
Nearly every island that the Straw Hats travel
to, they restore freedom to the citizens.
Like Joyboy before him, Luffy’s heart beats
in time with the drums of liberation.
The Okama Way is also a way of freedom.
In Bentham’s great sacrifice at Impel Down,
he grants the prisoners who allied with Luffy
freedom from the prison.
However, he also represents this theme to
the core of his
very being: as an Okama.
It’s no coincidence that Emporio Ivankov
and the Kamabakka Kingdom are aligned with
the Revolutionary Army.
Monkey D. Dragon opposes the authoritarian
rule of the World Government and the Celestial
Dragons.
With him, opposing this fascistic force, are
representatives of the oppressed people of
the One Piece world.
Bartholomew Kuma, who literally had his agency
stripped away to become a slave to the Celestial
Dragons; The Fishman Hack and Koala, representing
the Fishmen who are relegated to live beneath
the red line, away from the sunlight of the
surface; and Emporio Ivankov, ruler of the
Okama - the LGBT community of the One Piece
world.
In our real world, queer communities have
fought long and hard for decades against brutal
discrimination in order to be free to express
themselves and be able to love who they love.
And it’s the same in One Piece for figures
like Ivankov who allies himself with the Revolutionary
Army. (which, like, *come on Sanji*, you clearly
have some internalized prejudices you need
to work through).
From the moment we meet Bentham, he is unabashedly
who he wants to be.
He puts no limits on his self-expression.
He dresses the way he wants to.
He applies makeup the way he wants to.
He identifies fluidly with the gender that
he wants to.
His Clone-Clone fruit even lets him literally
become whoever he wants to.
This absolute freedom of expression and gender
is an extension of the freedom that Straw
Hat Luffy fights to bring to the world - one
of the central goals and themes of the entire
series.
Now, remaining in Impel Down, Bon-Chan is
the new Queen of Newkama Land.
As he says during his sacrifice in Alabasta,
“one may stray from the path of man.
One may stray from the path of woman.
But there is no straying from the path of
humanity.”
This is the Okama Way.
Or maybe Ivankov has already come to break
him out with the help of Luffy’s father.
And if you want to learn more about Monkey
D. Dragon and who he truly is, you really
can’t skip this video here.